inicio en las urnas pero la batalla por
la casa blanca entre joe biden y
donaldson podría terminar en los
tribunales el conteo de los votos sigue
aumentando la ventaja del candidato
demócrata hayden ganó en wisconsin por
un estrecho margen pero la campaña del
mandatario pidió un recuento de los
votos argumentando irregularidades en
varios condados
el equipo de champ también anunció una
demanda para evitar que continuará el
conteo de papeletas en michigan donde va
a ir en lidera dice que no tuvieron
acceso como observadores y exigen
revisar los votos
eso se acabó nos vamos a apegar nos
vamos a ganar la elección y de hecho ya
le hemos ganado es cuestión de votar
contar los votos con justicia la batalla
también se centra en pensilvania que
tiene hasta el viernes para contar las
boletas enviadas con fecha del 3 de
noviembre así lo determinó el tribunal
superior del estado pero los
republicanos apelaron la decisión en la
corte suprema que tiene la última
palabra
donald trump aseguró que el máximo
tribunal resolvería el resultado de la
contienda el presidente instaló allí
tres jueces y reforzó una mayoría de
seis magistrados conservadores frente a
tres liberales los demócratas temen que
los jueces puedan apoyar los planes del
líder republicano